konuşmak
bizim gibi Hayata hep görsel açıdan
bakan çizerler için biraz zor
1990'lı yıllarda
bir karikatür sergisi açmıştım karikatür
sevgisinin açılışında
Galeri temsilcisi bir konuşma yapıyor
Ben de seyircilerin arasında konuşmayı
dinliyorum
konuşmasının sonunda
şimdi de sözü çizelim bize devrediyorum
deyince
hiçbir konuşma hazırlamadığımı fark
ettim bütün gözler benim üzerime
çevrilmişti ve o sırada aklıma gelen bir
fikirle dedim ki Arkadaşlar ben zaten
konuşmayı biliyor olsaydım çizer
olmazdım O yüzden Buyurun sevgiyi
gezelim
beni tekim yine o konuşma ile ilgili
sınavlardan birindeyiz bugün Umarım
başarıyla atlatırız
benim çizgi yaşamım ne zaman başladı
1989 yılında İzmir'de Güzel Sanatlar
fakültesinde okurken ilk karikatürünü
dönemin efsanevi dergisi gırgıra
göndermekle başladı bu karikatür
yayınlandığında
İzmir'den İstanbul'a geldim amacım bu
derginin kadrosuna girebilmek
soluğu gırgır dergisinde ve Oğuz Aral'ın
kapısında aldım
oğuzlaral bizim için o dönem ve hala
aynı şekilde Efsane bir çizer
kapısı açıldı
uzun boylu Karizmatik bir ustamız Ben de
genç bir ergen olarak Oğuz abi diye
hamle yaptım beni hiç umursamadan dedi
ki git Pazartesi gel ve önümden yürüdü
gitti Ben tabi beklemeye devam ediyorum
Tekrar odası için geri gelince Oğuz abi
Ben İzmir'den geliyorum Pazartesileri
bilmiyorum dedim pazartesi günleri Ozan
al amatör karikatürcilerle
karikatür üzerine toplantılar yapıyormuş
Meğer benim Bundan haberim yok İzmir'den
geldiğimi duyunca döndü ve dikkatlice
bana baktı Tarık Sen misin dedi
düşünün Türkiye'nin her yanından
yüzlerce karikatür gönderen insan var ve
benim sadece bir karikatürümü görmüş ve
Adımı biliyor yani bu bizi ne kadar
dikkatle takip ettiğine dair güzel bir
anı
sonrasında derginin ileri gelen
çizelgelerinden Galip tekini çağırdı ve
dedi ki Hanım bu çocuğu yetiştirin
derginin kadrosuna girmem herhalde Bu
cümle ile tamamlanmış oldu
yanımda getirdiğim birkaç karikatür
galiptekine gösterdim o dönem Gırgır
dergisi amatör karikatürcülere oldukça
Cömert diyebileceğimiz telif ücretleri
yazıyor Ve benim karikatürlerim
karşılığında Galip Tekin bana sordu Dedi
ki bu karikatürler için ne kadar
istiyorsun ya bir genç için
o dönem ki karikatür kuru diyelim biz
buna herhalde 60-70 bin lira istemem
gerekir ben biraz cesur davrandım ve
dedim ki 200 bin lira istiyorum büyük
para
kısa bir sessizliğin ardından
Galip Tekin benimle ters bir pazarlık
başlattı 250 Olur tabii ki dedik
300-350-400 450 500
Ve nitekim o gün
Dergiye
5 kuruşsuz trene Kaçak binerek gelen Ben
muhasebe servisinden bütün ceplerin
Deste Deste paralarla 600 bin lirayla
ayrıldım
Tabii burada anlatmaya çalıştığım şey
başarılı bir iş adamının ne kadar çok
para kazandım hikayesi değil yani bu
coğrafyada binlerce yıldan bu yana
süregelen ustalık ustalık çıraklık
kurumunun çok güzel bir örneğini
yaşamıştım Bu arada iki ustamızı yad
etmiş olalım
ne güzel ki onlarla yolun kesişti
Sonrasında uzun yıllar dergide
karikatürcü ve çizgi romancı olarak
çalıştım
sonrasında gazeteler ve reklam sektörü
için yine hep çizgi ürettim
Bu arada tabi nedir geçim kaygısı diye
bir şey var hepimizin başımızın belası
Kredi kartları ödenecek
ödendikten sonra biraz belki Hedef
Büyütülecek araba alınacak ev alınacak
fakat geriye dönüp baktığınızda
giderek İçinizde büyüyen kocaman bir
soru işareti
acaba bu çizerlik maceram beni nereye
götürüyor şu anda olmak istediğim yerde
miyim soruları benim kafamda büyümeye
başladı ve biraz da
[Alkış]
Geleceğe dair
planlarımı gözden geçirmem gerektiğini
fark ettim yaptığım ilk şey Ferrari mi
satmak ve nepal'e gitmek
Tabii ki mümkün değil tek zaten Ferrari
yok Ne talebe gitmeye niyetim yoktu
geçmişime dönüp
çizerlik hayatımın
benim irademle gelişip gelişmediğini
sorguladım Ama gördüm ki
tümüyle tesadüfler ve mecburiyetler
şekillendirmişti benim hayatımı
bundan sonrası için
gurur duyabileceğin Sevebileceğim ve
ileriye dönük bir miras olarak
bırakabileceğim çalışmalara
odaklanmalıyım diye haince bir plan
yaptım
o yıllarda zaten
oldum olası çok sevdiğim haritalara
yoğunlaştım ve bir kitapla karşılaştım
ilk baskısı 1522 Yılında İtalya'da
yapılan stills of the Word Bu kitap
açıkçası benim için bir şeyleri
değiştirdi
kitabın içinde 250 tane dünya şehri
resmedilmiş
Tabii ki bu çizilen
çalışmalar bugün Hepsi birer sanat eseri
değerinde ama beni asıl ilgilendiren
kısmı kitabın hazırlık süreci düşünün
1522 yılında
250 kentine birer Seyyah yollayacaksınız
bu seyyahlar Kimisi yayan Kimisi at
sırtında Kimisi gemilere binerek
okyanuslar aşarak hedeflerine varacaklar
her birinin cebine birer kese altın
koysanız ciddi bir finansman demek ve
yıllar süren bu yolculuklardan geri
dönüp dönmeyecekleri de meçhul
batı kültürünün bu
kaydetmekteki ısrarı bende hayranlık
uyandırdı tabi tahmin edersiniz Bu
kitapta önemli bir bölüm
İstanbul'a ayrılmıştı
Biz İstanbul'u fethetmekle
övünüyoruz sahibi olmakla övünüyoruz
gördüm ki üzerinde yaşayan Bizler bu
şehri görsel olarak Hiç kaydetmemişiz
sadece ve sadece Kanuni döneminde
yaşayan Matrakçı Nasuh
bize bazı güzel çalışmalar bırakmış
bunların ışığında şöyle bir karar aldım
ben İstanbul doğumlu bir çizerim ve bu
görev kaçınılmaz olarak artık benim
sırtımda artık İstanbul'u çizmeliyim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
yavaştan bulabildiğim bütün boş
vakitlerde bu çalışmalara yoğunlaştım
ve 2017'ye geldiğimde artık reklam
sektöründen de yorulmuş olan ben
Tam zamanlı olarak haritalarıma
yoğunlaştım 2017 yılında
tarihi yarımada'yı konu alan bu
çalışmayla ortaya çıktığımda hedefin
oldukça küçüktü Yani biraz önce
anlattığım gibi sadece ve sadece tek
amacım evimde evimin duvarında Gurur
duyabileceğim
bir çalışmaydı fakat sosyal medyada
yayınlanınca beklediğimin çok üzerinde
tepkiler aldım ve o motivasyonla
Haydarpaşa garını konu alan Haydarpaşa
Panorama isimli çalışmayı yayınladım
niye haydarpaşa'yı seçtim çünkü
Haydarpaşa İstanbul hafızasında çok
güçlü bir yere sahip ve senelerden biri
ne yazık ki şehir Yaşamının dışında
tutuluyor
sonrasında
Eminönü Galata Köprüsü ve karaköy'ü
odağını alan bir çalışma yayınladım
Tabii bu çalışmalar
3-5 günde üretilen çalışmalar değil
aylar hatta yıllar süren çalışmalar
içinde bir sürü ayrıntı barındırıyor
korkunç bir dökümantasyon çalışması
gerektiriyor ben bu haritaları üretirken
kendimi tarihi mimariyi Hatta
İstanbul'daki boğaz akıntılarını
İstanbul'daki hayvan popülasyonunu
araştırırken buluyorum çok ilginç
yerlere götürüyor Beni Bu haritalar
haritaların içinde
[Müzik]
sadece İstanbul'un binaları değil aynı
zamanda hikayeleri ve kahramanları da
olmalıydı ve ben de naçizane toplumsal
sorumluluğun gereği olarak
yaşadığımız kentleşme sorunlarına rant
oyunlarına karşı bir tavır
belirlemeliydim yani haritanın bir
içeriği de olmalıydı
bunu da doğru bir şekilde inşa ettiğimi
düşünüyorum
şu anda Bu haritalar
Türkiye'de ve dünyada
zannediyorum binlerce evin ve ofisin
duvarlarını süslüyorlar Bu benim için
bir gurur kaynağı sonrasında 2021
yılında karşımıza nft diye bir şey
çıkıyor nedir nfti
yaşadığımız dijital dönüşümde sanatın
yeni bir konumlanışı yeni bir mecrası ve
ben de
teknolojiyi takip eden biri olarak
ülkemizde en etkili konusunda ilk
öncülerden biri oluyorum ve Uluslararası
bir takım koleksiyonerler tarafından
eserlerim hatırı sayılır paralara ne
dağlara satın alınıyor
[Alkış]
birilerinin peşinden gitmeyi reddettim
ve kendime
yepyeni Sıfır kilometre bir alan açtım
bu açtığım alanda çizdiğim yolda Tabii
ki kaçınılmaz olarak
birinciydim ve bunun keyfini yaşadım
haritalar beni çok güzel yerlere getirdi
ve bundan sonra da bu yolculuk Bu yol
beni nerelere götürecek Ben de merakla
bekliyorum dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]